sophie cluzel au centre marcel pagnol
d'achères la secrétaire d'état chargé
des personnes handicapées s'est rendu ce
mardi 28 juillet dans ce centre de
loisirs inclusif accueillant des enfants
en situation de handicap
le dispositif est géré par l'association
du fun pour tous sur la commune depuis
il ya une éducatrice spécialisée qui en
poste en binôme avec une animatrice et
l'objectif c'est d'utiliser les loisirs
et l'inclusion comme outil de
l'éducation spécialisée pour continuer à
accompagner les enfants dans leurs
acquisitions autour de l'autonomie de la
socialisation et de leur épanouissement
pour qu'ils s'éclatent comme les enfants
et c'est aussi pour pouvoir proposer des
modes de garde famille comme toutes les
autres familles en fête
au total le dispositif permet de
recevoir six enfants de la commune et
des villes voisines en situation de
handicap sont accueillis en petits
groupes le soir les mercredis et pendant
les vacances scolaires avec les autres
jeunes présents dans le centre
une démarche qui séduit le gouvernement
donc c'est vraiment ce que l'on porte
c'est exactement cette société inclusive
qu'on est en train de bâtir grâce
justement en fait que les jeunes
apprennent la différence et qu'elle
devienne naturel cette différence il
faut accompagner ces dispositifs c'est
pour ça que j'ai dédié des fonds au sein
de la caf pourquoi financer ses projets
la matinée s'est terminée par un repas
entre tous les participants
l'association aimerait ouvrir des unités
comme celle ci à montigny le bretonneux
plaisir ou en corse anciens l'école